the giants and the seattle mariners game
two of the season and for the giants
already trying to come back after a
horrible loss blowing a six to one lead
in the eighth inning
on the hill tonight four the seattle
mariners will be uh you say kikuchi
kikuchi last season nine stars two and
four with a five one seventy hour he's
got a good fastball you'll see mid to
high 90s with the velocity in a fastball
he can sink and cut the fastball he's
got a curveball slider but his best
specialty pitch is a changeup pitched
seven years
in japan with cebu with 69 and 45 with a
2.69 era so he is a guy that
got good stuff
there you
go good start he's got solano two and
two with two out the wind-up and the
two-two on the way and it's strike three
called he got him looking with a
breaking ball he strikes out solano you
say kikuchi takes care of the giants one
two three here in the top of the first
inning
is johnny cueto about ready to face
mitch henniger equator who is always
very entertaining out there always
varying his delivery the slide step and
he strikes him out swinging with another
changeup
taking care of the giants one two three
in the top of the first with a couple of
strikeouts here's the stretch and the
one-two pitch strike three called you
say kikuchi has faced four batters here
at the start of the game and there is
strikeout number three
as he gets evan longoria looking holy
smokes what a start veteran darren ruff
went two for five against the mariners
last season hit a big home run in one of
the four victories in four games the
giants had against the marist here's the
stretch and again the 2-2 on the winner
up swing and a miss for strike three
another strikeout for you say a fastball
up and away and ruff could not find it
three strikeouts in a row for kikuchi he
fans four of the first five batters that
he faces tonight against the giants wow
here's the stretch and the one one on
the way swinging a fly ball lifted into
right field down the line toward the
corner near the seats hanager running
out of room leaps up at the edge of the
seats wet that angle out toward the line
haniger makes the catch and that will
retire the side that'll bring up catcher
luis terence this one is setting up to
be a pitchers duel here's the pitch of
the way swinging a fly ball down the
left field line fair ball in toward the
corner rounding third heading home
coming down the stretch and scoring is
fraley and it's second is terrence with
a two out rbi double and the mariners
take a one-nothing lead over the giants
here in the bottom half of the second
luis terrence first at bat of the year
drives in a run nothing like a good
old-fashioned two out rbi
one on one run in two outs here in the
bottom of the second a one nothing lead
here's the pitch and a swing and a miss
and yes indeed there's that change up
against strike three plato strikes out
the side but the mariners get a run we
go to the top of the third hour score
mariners one and the giants nothing he
faces buster posey to begin the third
inning buster back and back in the
lineup tonight first pitch he swings
against kikuchi and drives one to deep
center field tramell is back and it is
gone buster posey has done it again two
games two home runs
wow
and that one was as impressive or more
so than the one last night which he
pulled and hit very hard this one he hit
just to the right of straightaway center
field and over the leaping attempt of
taylor trammell over that eight-foot
high wall
one out two aboard now evan white comes
up and steps evan white the pitch to
white swing line drive sucked into
center field henniger coming in to score
here comes france he's being waved in
the throw home play at the plate no tag
france slides in feet first
evan white jumping on the first pitch he
sees from johnny cueto has given the
mariners the leader right back he drives
in two it's 3-1 mariners in the bottom
of the third watch hope played umpire
the old marine las diaz watch this
sir yes sir give himself a good look
it's the most traffic that gucci's had
here today for the fourth two on two
away the stretch and the two two on the
way to flores swung out in a fly ball
center field backing up trammell near
the warning track taylor is there and he
makes the catch that will retire the
side
usa gets out of a jam here in the top of
the fourth and the giants leave the tie
and run stranded
you say studying the signs
taking a lot of time between pitches he
worked with a quicker
tempo and rhythm early in the game
here's the pitch on the way fastball
swing animus for strike three and there
is strikeout number seven for you say
kikuchi fans buster posey leading off
the top of the fifth inning and the
strikeouts keep on coming number seven
in the books two out one on
tying right at the plate
you say checks the runner devon the lead
at first pitch on the way swing and a
miss for strike three strike down number
eight for you say kikuchi and that's it
for slater and the giants here in the
top of the fifth inning the strikeouts
have been coming in bunches for usa
we're at the halfway point we go to the
bottom of the fifth so here is evan
longoria who has struck out looking and
who has walked
longoria hits a high drive to right
it is out of here
and this game is tied
it's his second of the season and the
second to right field and he got the
arms extended and
drove it back into the third row of the
seats out there in right center field
just stays inside and rides it right out
with some backspin darren ruff he struck
out swinging twice he fires home
swinging this a shot out of a cannon to
center field tramell tumbling and taylor
trammell makes the catch the barrel
rolls in a left center and somehow puts
it in the glove taylor tremell in his
second big league game hard to his right
diamond cats and jake freely enjoyed it
this is the guy you want coming up
solano's two for three tonight a couple
of singles you scored a run
giants can go ahead 3-1
is pulled
fair just down the third base line and
just fair crawford can come in to score
yostremski speeding around third and
they're going to wave him home here
comes the throw and it's offline
yostremski slides in safely on the throw
solano into second it's five to three
giants donovan solano comes through
again evan longoria the batter five
three giants
longoria bounces this one and it's under
the glove of dylan moore solano trying
to score and he is going to make it
solano was in safely with the sixth run
of the game at six to three giants
terrence with a double in the second
that knocked in the first run of the
game the pitch
fastball to the outside strikes him out
swinging
and that's the game the giants get their
first win
of the
2021 season